je rentrais chez vers 1 1 pas dû souvent
mettre les pieds au sein du bloc
opératoire et n'a pu gêner n'a jamais dû
travailler avec des intermèdes piste
[Musique]
nous craignons qu'à terme il y une
pénurie d'infirmiers anesthésistes que
les infirmiers ne veuille plus faire
cette profession parce que pour 13 euros
de plus par mois le jeu n'en vaudrait
pas la chandelle au vu des risques que
nous prenons tous les jours et de la
dangerosité potentielle de ce que nous
faisons tous les jours
[Musique]
il ya des décrets qui sont sortis et des
nouvelles
professions qui ont été créés par le
gouvernement donc les affaires et
pratiques avancées depuis 60 ans voire
même plus que nous existons nous sommes
dans la pratique avancée et danse dans
cette nouvelle loi nous n'existons pas
et nous sommes mis complètement à
l'écart
[Musique]